all right man bullet cat podcast we got
my guy nems in the building
coney island's finest that's right let's
go man we're gonna have him uh you know
do what you know him to do bing bong
let's go come on man we in l.a too let's
do this yeah [ __ ] your life coney allen
yeah
[ __ ] your life
bing bong
i gave rappers the benefit scream [ __ ]
your life so that they'd have to
remember it pain splattered with
ignorance hop in the back city your whip
and blow your dome matter all in your
[ __ ] fat bastard degenerate still
[ __ ] love them like ellen degeneres
i'll give you the business you can tell
that i'm generous xanthes and perks let
me sell you some medicine they hit you
with more time when you are feeling that
sentence and every new year i pray i can
get to another cause the [ __ ] that i've
been through you don't get to recover
with no deal bought a crib as a gift to
my mother then i gave her a kiss told
that [ __ ] that i love her
i jumped into this [ __ ] feet first with
a deep thirst are you rhyming this long
and need work your chain garbage your
weed dirt and your mannequin was [ __ ]
i'll set fire to his resting peace shirt
you ain't got a front for me go front
for your people i swim with the sharks
with a bucket of seafood strap on my lap
give a [ __ ] if it's legal i'll sell you
a hat with a bundle of diesel huh eating
lovely go get you a plate we got dope
and crack on the phone it's chicken or
steak you ran into the jake now you
don't want to be a player go ask bastian
lance who's the mayor put the fuego to
the base raise it to the plate all these
speculations on the paper that i make
let you gossip with the nina she'll take
you on a date don't let the grand fool
you i'll break your [ __ ] face i ride
with the desi put your mind on my prezi
tried to let it slide but my pride
wouldn't let me my booth the [ __ ] is
running down in macy's with the lizzies
like bars like my chains all these
[ __ ] heavy got 100 rounds ready
every line is a big fact i have my mans
post about your crib where your kids at
want you out the door your wifey gets
kidnapped all it took is 500 with an
eighth and a six-pack i paid my dues but
i ain't never been extorted my [ __ ]
gets what she wants his loyalty gets
rewarded my dudes ain't left the block
they've never been crossed the border
lil homie now watch your mouth remember
who gives the orders uh got your wife on
my camcorder and my man serves grams of
your granddaughter you talking reckless
like you got bodies under your belt we
checked the fouls that was vehicular
manslaughter stop at five or eight ain't
no rapping it's live as me my rap sheets
say attempt murders in armed robberies
so i'm not one for the brick talk if
you're a demon then i'm [ __ ] satan
with the pitchfork yeah
[ __ ] your life stupid big bomb
satan with the pitchfork man be out here
let's go congo out right now right now
stupid let's go we thought we're done
but
yeah multiple clips yeah we get it done
clips
coney island style man yeah
let the beat up a little bit turn that
beat up man yeah
yo
yo uh huh yo ah bravo we clapping at you
standing ovation still tow boots kick
your whole face live from coney island
not mill basin three for fifty for them
fiends that are still basin
gorilla nems i'm a gladiator she trying
to kick dope chain it to the radiator
merch trucks in the denali [ __ ]
navigator got your [ __ ] sucking me off
like i'm an hour later
that [ __ ] gunter said i'm sort of
awesome my people's got them bricks at
the border crossing yup your man's a
snitch duke you order off them and you
know it's [ __ ] your life like a fourth
abortion
you could duck or get hit i'm wondering
why my name is always stuck on your lips
i'ma start [ __ ] your [ __ ] then buck
50 your face with a razor that was
laying in a bucket of piss bong
hold up i don't worry where the hoes at
they all living in my phone waiting on
that call back asking cause she stand on
her own and where her goals at i wonder
who the [ __ ] raise these rappers and
where they codes at
cause once you go bad you can't switch
back i'd rather be broke with principles
than be a rich rat
[ __ ] i let my nuts hang i got a big sack
abusing all these rappers with bars they
scared their head back
look
and i don't even have to rap imagine you
really sold all them drugs you rap about
homie i don't saw more hats than that i
started off in battle rap but i'm the
only one that made a career after that
i got street knowledge and book smarts
a [ __ ] scholars mind with a crook's
heart
body everything moving before the hook
starts how you talk gangster with shook
thoughts i'm trying to grow weed in
oregon i'm visiting farms you
head-to-toe in supreme but you live with
your moms grown man alcoholic duke your
liver is gone [ __ ] you look like a
[ __ ] dick that grew arms
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] dick arms